strome softly off the glass Frank forano who
has been red hot to start off this season 11
goals already tracked it down back to the point
and that long Slap Shot from Cam Fowler Yosi
pokes it back towards the point an intercept by
vatrano out to Adam Henrik short-handed looking
for a return vatrano oh the backhander denied
by UC Soros short-handed and a terrific look for
the ducksss and for a lot of coaches you love to
see this butron to highlight it along the boards
makes a good defensive play on the peny hill
keeps his feet moving he's absolutely flying
up the ice for a long time he will quarterback
here with this second unit for Nashville wrist
shot glove save is made by Gibson that's around
the Dasher funny bounce off the side Blast Off
the outside of the Anaheim net Ryan stro lost
the puck thrown towards the net pad save made
by Gibson lazon crashing in he puts it behind
the net booty back to the point Fabro across
for the one-time by Hy that's on net or rather
McCarron by Gibson Fabro keeps it alive at the
point and more offensive zone pressure put on
none save by Gibson Banks one off the board's
to sissons nice Handle by Parson through center
paronan with a drop deadens it on the line and
a long backhander gobbled up by Gibson off the
laon look Cody glass in the corner walks it to
the half boards down to the goal line to the
forehand flaming it high and wide with sizen
and that allows oy across Evangelista swings one
back to forsberg forsberg wrist shot glove save
made by Gibson and he will hold forsberg to the
half wall on the near side now it is Yosi takes
the shot forsberg wrer that caught some iron
and stays out of the net a blistering wrist
shot from from forsberg solv Gibson but caught
the post and now it is Yosi one time drive and
Gibson slides from right to left to take one
away from O'Reilly responsible both teams not
trying to force a change silverberg sets up
Max Jones save made by SOS possibly the best
test he has seen so far and a penalty is now
upcoming in his skates Fowler keeps it alive
power play almost over wrist shot carams just wide
looking for it UC Soros out of the box is carier
from his perspective but to no avail forsberg
with the final minute approaching here in the
period fires one save Gibs him through traffic
he made it look awfully easy exactly Nyquist up
high to Yosi here is forsberg again another
try another save made by Gibson trusted his
positioning into the trapezoid Den iist El by
O'Reilly walked in by Carri got it on that and
a rebound score forsburg BS it out of midair
it's an even strength goal and it breaks the
ice the Predators on the board as forsberg has
his seventh of the season and third efforts on
this play fr's doing a nice job with the puck
movement keeping high on fber in front of the
net number nine opens his blade on the tip it goes
up and over the air and I thought the World Series
was over but he had different ideas this is a
bunt he bunts this one number nine watch him here
as he'll bunt it gruz sent one right through the
slot A C back to the point that shot on Nick and
a pad save is made by USI Soros then missing the
net and that's scaled off the glass by Carrick a
chance possible odd man Rush Johnston puns it
on net Soros moving to his right made the save
Gibson was ready silverberg watches that pass flow
through ends up centering pass and a save made by
UC Soros he took one away from Max Jones that's
the same one timer he worked on this morning in
the pregame skate power play just about over it
is now over one timer there save made by Soros
he games when they have scored first which is an
anomaly to say the least as they're trying to hold
on to this lead tonight Roman Yosi on net save
made by Gibson through traffic across the line
by Carrick wrist shot sails wide and car's all
the way out to silverberg on that blocker save
made by yussi Saros to Nyquist down low forand
glass pulls it into the paint and looking for
it at the side of the net as well as O'Reilly
the back pass though from forsberg into the
skates of forsberg unable to clear though his
Fowler taken back by O'Reilly snap just wide
by Nyquist it may have glanced off the Blocker
of Gibson O'Reilly moves in wrist shot there's
a blocker save made by Gibson 33 seconds to go
on the power play controlled Again by Yosi nist
right back to Roman Yosi makes the shot down to
the goal line O'Reilly puts it off the shoulder
of Gibson yeli with a drive Robin yeli on the
power play two nothing nationville [Music]
outstanding efforts by Ryan O'Reilly not
one not twice but three times and Gibson
up to the task watch Roman Yosi that is an
absolute be top shelf and I'm sure his good
friend Roger Federer will be proud of that one
that is an ace off to McTavish on the Move Dro
to vrono moves in behind the net patrono
in the far Corner patrono saucers a pass
to Fowler with some room R shot score the Ducks
are on the board has Cam Fowler the rer to beat
uros and we've got a one goal game Frankie
patrono that Engineers this entire Play Zone
entry you're expecting him to be a a shooter
Around the Net stop up draws triple coverage
goes across the ring over to cam Valor and Valor
one leg over the fire hydrant makes no mistake
this one glances off the defender and you'll
see it just sneak inside that short side as it
glances off [Music] Delo pivots into the trapezoid
fights his way through contact and stumbles lost
his balance now aine in exit Perry right down
Broadway shot the red goodus ties the game in
two the defenseman got loose between the circles
Radco goodas now here they come on offense due
the Ducks and Radco Gus is going to time this
one perfectly I mentioned earlier about coming
down Broadway Gus literally right down the other
side of Broadway unchecked in the slot that's a
frustration thing for the general manager Barry
trots watch good is s and white in the middle
of your screen I mean he comes down unscathed
handle the Pu behind his own net but right go g
yeah and reek after that R wiad pass
O'Reilly the first two it throws it
out in front of his own net R goas
takes the shot back andine and tries
walk her hold back anded the assist to Redco Gus
and Anaheim has come from two nothing down to take
the lead just said he's back Radco Gus keys this
playing it's a nice for check effort here by the
veteran Adam Henri F1 colorin the veteran but
look at Gus sells the shot D Tod to his partner
back inan who wires this one watch Radco Gus seven
in the middle of your screen in white look at him
drifting drifting support up ready ah little touch
pass over to backing him O'Reilly wins the draw
it's up to Barry HS the back that shot through
traffic safe made by Gibson it's loose on the
doorstep Gibson snow angel in the blue paint to
make sure he covers up pass gets this is street
hockey extraordinaire 1 2 3 4 it's Parson the
draw loose in the circle Korn behind the net
skates out the final few seconds it's another
third period come from behind win for Anaheim